Now, onto the secondary pollutants.
Ozone is created in the atmosphere.
The full chemical story is extraordinarily complex.
But a simple version involves three precursors-- nitrogen oxide,
carbon monoxide, and volatile organic compounds.
When combined with sunlight, this mixture creates ozone.
These volatile organic compounds can be anything from gasoline
that evaporates from the gas tanks of cars
to isoprenes-- organic compounds released by trees.
Ozone chemistry is surprising.
In general, when one mixes oxidizers and hydrocarbons,
one expects to reduce the amount of oxidizer.
When the origin of ground level ozone-- also known as smog-- around Los Angeles
was first discovered in the 1950s, it was a big surprise
to chemists-- a mixture of oxidizers and hydrocarbons
is being cooked in the atmosphere to produce
ozone and even more powerful oxidizer.
It&#39;s worth mentioning that the ozone layer in the stratosphere
is something we want.
It protects the surface of the Earth from UV
that would otherwise sterilize the planet.
On the other hand, ozone in the lower atmosphere
is something we do not want because ozone breaks down
essentially any organic compound it touches--
from the service of your lungs to the plastic parts on your car
or the growing parts of plants.
Stratospheric ozone, good.
Surface ozone, bad.
Controlling ozone is complicated because the amount of ozone produced
depends in a sensitive way on the mixture of the precursors.
In some conditions, cutting NOx emissions
can actually lead do an increase in ozone.
Perhaps because of this complexity, the US
has made only very moderate progress on reducing ozone exposure in cities--
roughly a 20% reduction since 1980.